here's a picture a very simple picture
but your next line is well why should i
subscribe to the new water view and
quite simply it's to attain regular
Georgia content uploaded straight until
YouTube feed hello and welcome to the
new alt review your source for
everything anime and manga and today
Jojo things are happening and as such we
are going to be delving into a
discussion surrounding part to being
battle tendency and more accurately the
Great Divide of love and hate for this
part of the story within the fan base
and I feel like I need to do this
because yes Jojo is a divisive series in
general but what I've noticed from the
hundreds upon hundreds of comments that
I've read from you guys is that opinions
on part two are radically different and
at least from my anecdotal experience
it's pretty much split right down the
middle and I get that this might shock
people who believe that part two is
pretty much universally adored but the
reality is that is far from the case and
also to clear out where I stand right at
the beginning
I love Part two I think it's a nice
tight piece of storytelling in my Jojo
pot rankings video I put it at number
three however I did also ask you
wonderful people to articulate for me
why you do or do not enjoy battle
tenancy and as a result I do think I
understand the situation for those of
you who are not keen on it I'm going to
present the arguments for and against it
here today to open this discussion
though I will restate my overall opinion
which is that part two was an
exceptional evolution of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure which took some framework laid
out in part one and developed it into a
short and sweet story with a far greater
cast of characters as well as
significantly improved action and comedy
but I am also very willing to
acknowledge that my overwhelmingly
positive impression of battle tendency
may have to do with where in the series
if spliced because they do have very
fundamental issues with parts 1 & 3
there are plenty of criticisms to be had
and we're going to start with the most
common one that I found which is that
the characters of battle tendency simply
aren't all that great the one general
exception to that statement seems to be
Joseph who by and large people seem to
agree takes a very strong command of the
series not everyone but most however the
real problems come within two main areas
one of which being the villains and the
other being the side characters in
general now to explore the first I do
find the pillar men as a group to be far
more effective of an antagonistic
presence compared to part one dear but I
will say that a lot of the heavy lifting
here is placed squarely onto the
shoulders of WaMu who is by far the best
explored villain in part two to the
point where he becomes quite likable and
even humanized unlike the rest of the
pillar men specifically cause and here
is where I 100% agree with the criticism
of battle
because I found cause to be the weakest
aspect of the entire series and quite
possibly one of the weakest aspects of
giorgo in general and to put it simply
he was just kind boring
an evil bro who does evil things for
evils yay that's fun I mean yes he did
have this like sliver of personality and
that he displayed general care for the
world around him whether it be dogs or
flowers and it does seem to be
specifically humanity that cars took
issue with which actually had the
potential to be an interesting
exploration but all we ever really
received from cars were bread crumbs of
a character that didn't fully form into
a delicious and tagging istic loaf and
that is a real shame because if cars had
a more profound presence and I don't
think there would be so much of an
argument surrounding part two but this
is an incredible detriment I find it
much more forgivable though due to the
length apart - it's a story that you can
really zip through and enjoy and cars
doesn't demand an incredible amount of
time and energy to invest in - so you
have the option of just you know
watching a reading about him and then
forgetting him it's not like the main
antagonist of part three and onwards
where if you're not a huge fan of them
that's too bad because you're going to
be stuck with them for an awfully long
time not that there are many of those
thankfully but sticking to characters
for now another common ailment that
appears to be expressed is
dissatisfaction with the sign characters
particularly that of Caesar now he
doesn't fall into a car situation of
just being a plain flat individual but
once again due to the short nature of
battle tendency it is arguable that
Caesar did not have the time necessary
to experience a character arc that is
worthy of his rather grand exit from the
series and of course the moment where
Joseph screams shiva is once obviously a
gigantic meme within the series in
general but this is also narrative Lee
intended to be the largest moment of
emotional resonance within Padel
tendency that goes on to solidify
joseph´s resolved to defeat The
Pillowman and it just doesn't seem to
have that impact for many people because
the journey from introducing Caesar as a
rival then forming a friendship and
finally passing away can be seen as very
rushed and I can certainly say that
perspective although I don't necessarily
agree with it myself I personally think
that Caesars presence in battle tendency
at a phenomenal effect and when he died
I felt like I'd lost a character and in
my opinion that's exactly how it should
have felt at the same time it's very
difficult for me to argue that that's
how everyone should have seen this event
because the groundwork that was laid was
the absolute bare minimum so I can't
blame anyone for just wanting that
little bit more and one more character
that often gets a mention is Lisa Lisa
and here I'm going to agree with part-2
criticisms yet again because I was
actually
really frustrated at how underutilize
she was you know he is Dan's probably
the greatest Hummer master we have had
access to and she does a grand total of
practically nothing and the sigh I let
out when she was dispatched so easily by
cars was well one of the most extreme
disappointment possible because all I
wanted from Lisa Lisa was for her to
have a decent action sequence which we
never really got and in regards to her
overall as a mentor not a whole lot was
done there either and actually she's
probably far less developed of a mental
than baron zeppeli in part one so I
think that Lisa Lisa is a very awkward
character who is saved by her relation
to Joseph and the eventual backstory we
get regarding George that was definitely
my favorite Lisa Lisa moment is all of
this a deal breaker for me not at all
but it is frustrating and I very much
empathize with those who do not like it
and I'd also like to count to the
character grievance by highlighting
Stroheim who I feel was perfectly
utilized in the role that he was given
Stroheim very much adds a much-needed
layer of texture to battle tendency by
representing a third faction getting
involved in the home on warriors versus
stacked naked men conflict in fact
without Stroheim I think that battle
tendency does risk the danger of being a
rather flat story but his presence only
enhances part two and it goes to show
that not every side character was a
waste of potential but getting into
story now and this is what I will most
often praise battle tenancy for and it
has a lot to do with the idea that this
part is consistently moving and
developing it's not like the generally
accepted format of Jojo which started
from Part three onwards to be fair but
basically it was begin with an
interesting premise then spend 90% of
the series fighting intellectually
intriguing battles that don't really
progress the story and then a big
climactic conclusion so in retrospect
battle tendency really does stand out
because it has no moments of what seemed
like forced obstacles that bring the
story to a standstill it all just flows
very naturally and that is something
that I personally very much appreciate
within the context of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure as a whole however when you
take the story of battle tenancy and
compare it to storytelling in general
just outside of the dojo scope then I
don't know if it comes out looking so
great anymore because when you get down
to it it is a fairly simple concoction
there is certainly nothing revolutionary
about it or while the cooking but it is
a story which by default is going to
propel that into the stratosphere of the
dirt apart rankings because it has such
little competition in that realm because
I mean what's going to give it a run for
its money phantom blood follows an
evolving narrative yeah
but it's far more generic and I think
that the only solid argument you could
make for a fantastic narrative all the
way through would be steel ball Ron or
perhaps Jojo Leon golden Lin's maybe but
I would personally argue against it it's
just that everything from pottery
onwards does follow that
before-mentioned formula where it feels
like the large majority of the series is
just roadblock after roadblock after
roadblock that never really achieves
anything narrative wise that's not the
case with panel tenancy everything that
happens is propelling the narrative
forward so battle tendency does kind of
end up as the default winner in the
minds of many through its competent
dominance within this one narrative
category but the opposite is also very
true as battle tendency can be default
loser because many many Jojo fans love
that established format the stand of the
weak business and so because part two
does not subscribe to that it can very
much be an automatic loser which is
entirely down to personal preference of
storytelling and while we're on that the
fact that it also does come from the
priest and era can very much hurt part
2's perception because stands are
obviously the lifeblood of Jojo and part
two doesn't have any of that life to it
and that's fair enough if you're reading
or watching the series for fun
intriguing stands in which case I can
understand the battle tendency just is
not going to be your jam but I also want
to examine this topic from a more meta
perspective because a very fascinating
point was brought up by a few of you
which is that it's not so much the
battle tendency is considered to be a
bad part it's more that it's impression
has been harmed by perception within the
fanbase and one way of presenting this
case is the idea of overhyping media I
mean for example I can say all I want
the panel tendency is a brilliant part
but if you have not seen or read it then
after hearing my statement your
expectations will have been artificially
raised and then once you delve into the
media yourself and you find that it is a
simply generally enjoyable competent
story then despite all of that you may
feel a bit disappointed because my
statement promised you so much more than
what part 2 was capable of delivering so
over the years if there has been ground
support for part 2 to the point where it
is built up a solid status within the
Jojo community then there is quite
naturally going to be an anti part 2
faction that develops full of people who
will promise something amazing and now
have a skewed perception of battle
tendency because it did not live up to
artificially inflated expectations and
for those people who already believe
that battle tendency is overhyped and
they are going to be subject to their
own confirmation bias generally seeking
out and accepting opinions that support
their initial view rather than
challenging their thinking which over
time only further degrades their opinion
on the
by the way that works in the opposite
direction as well with part-2 superfans
dismissing concerns of those who aren't
so keen on it and only accepting
opinions that agree with their own
thoughts and that is a recipe for the
extreme divide in the opinion that I
have observed people seem to either rank
part-2 incredibly high or the next two
if not smack-bang in last place there
doesn't seem to be a lot of room for
nuance here and take this even a step
further this can also end up affecting
the impression of battle tenancy without
even taking the series itself into
account and this can occur when big fans
apart to become hyper critical of other
parts due to everything they lack the
battle tendency claims as a strength
like consistent story for example now
what results from this is a very
annoying human phenomena where because
you may have had a bad encounter and
dislike a particular individual then you
also come to dislike the things of that
person likes let's say your personal
favorite part is attacked by a battle
tendency lover then your natural
reaction might be rather sadly to bring
a sense of dislike on to part two
because of that individual and you see
this an awful lot in politics and it's
an especially unproductive view but it
does exist so yeah and the final point
I'd like to address is that I also saw a
lot of comments stating your dislike
towards battle tendency because it
doesn't fit in with the original giorgo
trilogy and I guess that's primarily
because it doesn't focus on dealing with
deer so it can be a bit disconnected in
that way but it is one point that I
wholeheartedly disagree with if anything
the part that feels out of place in the
original trilogy is Stardust Crusaders
because it takes what JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure was and turns it into an
almost completely unrecognizable product
with an entirely new power system and
narrative structure whereas I find that
part 1 and part 2 go together pretty
fantastically with the pillar men being
in natural escalation of the stern
mosque mystery an expansion of home on
and a cast of characters that tie
incredibly closely to that of the part 1
crew and I actually wish that Stardust
Crusaders had been able to escalate this
further because in my opinion just
bringing back deer who doesn't quite cut
it and it still feels like it's an
adventure which I guess is also fine I
just think that saying that pot 2 is the
old one out is a very strange statement
but once again to each their own as for
me though I've come out of this
discussion with a new appreciation for
the flaws of battle tendency and I
completely understand those who rate
this part exceptionally low the story is
admittedly pretty standard many of the
characters are quite underutilized and
the part suffering from over hype is
only going to exacerbate those issues I
still think for what it is though battle
10
he comes close to maximizing what it
wants to be in the time allotted to it
and once again the fact that this part
is so short makes many if not all of the
very real issues much more forgivable
than issues in later parts because they
are far more enduring tales and as a
result set issues can become quite the
test of endurance but what do you guys
think please do feel free to share your
thoughts on battle tendency in the
comments below
well even join my discourse server if
you're keen for some more Georgia
content then please do go and check out
all my other videos we'll even subscribe
to the channel for regular Georgia
wander delivered straight into your
YouTube feed but for now this has been
the New World review and I'll see you
next time